vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui vous avez déjà
un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel bien qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec écoute le plus de baladou
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus le si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sfr bienvenue
aux sans filtre le podcast où on parle
de ce qu'on veut avec nos invités dati
seach ph quentin avec moi doom plantes
wisdom qui présente le podcast
aujourd'hui de commencer ça aujourd'hui
c'est encore une fois encore 29 qui
tenait une boutique de linge
en ce moment on peut pas y aller sur
place évidemment cause de confinement
mais ils ont une plateforme en ligne en
ligne sur parlophone d'acheter vos
vêtements là dessus on dit vraiment pour
stoke - cholet personnellement en
boutique avant avant la fin du monde -
confinement et on disparaît gentil et
puis ils ont offert vraiment de
problèmes dont sept tests que vous voyez
ici les t-shirts à péage en pleine white
type puis ça c'est de la bombe un bon je
vais plein de rien mieux super belle
expérience en boutique avec un autre
parent bon c'est pas bon service examen
puis espère bostock aussi donc tout ce
que tout ce qui tend à gaz un est dispo
en ligne et en plus on a un code promo
sf 15 dont l avons 15 % de rabais sur
vos achats avec un gant 29 une
entreprise de québec alors on parle
beaucoup d'acheter local
c'est vraiment une occasion d'encourager
une entreprise du québec ont plus de
cinquante boutiques à travers le québec
le nouveau-brunswick
alors je vous encourage fortement de
regarder ce qui justement c'est une
bonne occasion en ce moment de faire ses
achats des ménages en ligne alors en
garde
29 tout à fait ce nom encore une fois je
vous parle de vegan n'est pas plate
forme d'une peuplade c'est la compagnie
que j'ai cofondé en fait on fait un
service de livraison de mai 100 % des
italiens à domicile c'est des repas
surgelés
vous avez juste besoin de commander sa
donc triple w point vmp points c'est à
la première phase on a remis des plats
pardon aux professionnels de la santé du
chien là la deuxième phase on va
remettre 25% de tous nos profits en
plats surgelés à des banques
alimentaires donc on va choisir une
banque alimentaire et on va remettre des
plats surgelés pour essayer de faciliter
la tâche à des gens qui n'ont pas
nécessairement tous les moyens de se
nourrir donc triple w point vmp points 6
heures pour commander vos plats puis ben
ouais c'est vraiment packing bon
l'egypte à ce parce que c'est ma
compagnie c'est vraiment fois qu'il bon
sinon des semaines sur podcast moi c'est
pas ma compagnie je consomme que c'est
faux king bon on s'y arrête cette
semaine de vacances vraiment content de
recevoir
arnaud se lire ou celui qui si vous êtes
moindrement sur instagram vous suivez un
petit peu les personnalités québécoises
où l'avez sûrement vu qu'il fait
d'élèves du lundi au jeudi
c'est puissant c'est drôle c'est
improvisé
il ya plein de monde qui passe là dessus
c'est vraiment un boss je pense du
confinement le chaque jour de semaine
justement à 22h à nos celui qui tenait
provocateur au repas qui est inquiétant
un humoriste qui avait sa tournée de la
campagne m
ainsi démarré leur finalement bien
évidemment c'est impossible mais comme
on en a parlé dans le podcast se
trouvent d'autres moyens d'être créatif
de faire de contenus en ligne des vidéos
d'élèves de ce négoce paraît-il gengoux
super gentil six pages nru c'était
vraiment un grand plaisir de le recevoir
j'espère que vous allez aimer le podcast
comme une autre on apprécie le moment
ouais pire merci encore à tous le monde
qui nous écoutent chez qui en ce moment
est la qualité moins au rendez-vous que
caroline en studio avec course mais
c'est le fun de voir que vous êtes
encore nombreux à nous écouter à chaque
semaine depuis que mais qu'on peut vous
faire passer deux heures plus rapidement
dans cette période difficile fait que
sans plus attendre on vous souhaite la
santé la santé à vos proches c'est
vraiment l'un portable puis on vous
souhaite d'apprécier cette conversation
si donc bon podcasts ou en écoute les
amis
[Musique]
arnaud va bien ça va bien 1 comment
comment se passe ta quarantaine apport
les soirs parce qu'on va revenir sur les
soirs plus tôt mais en général comment
va la santé physique et mentale ça va
bien je te dirais que c'est un peu dur
penda dans le sens où il ya des journées
que je suis vraiment optimiste positif
je compte passer du temps que ma femme
et moi j'ai un bébé de cinq mois à la
maison
j'habite avec ma femme aussi donc on est
on est trois abeilles se confiner il ya
des journées moyens plus faciles que
d'autres se disent avec par exemple
c'est fragile la piscine il suffit
qu'une journée quelque chose se passe
pas bien il fait pas beau d'heure où
j'ai bu un peu trop de points la veille
qui ça se peut que la santé mentale
fragile parce que c'est celui de
l'anxiété
je pense que la question de quand est ce
qu'on va sortir de tuer et ben
angoissante pour beaucoup de gens puis
si j'avais une date de fin tu me diras y
restant semaine en ligue 1 mais le fait
que le lyonnais ont connu beaucoup
devant moi ça fait que je trouve ça plus
difficile et ce qui érode parce que toi
toi ce moment même tu serai en tournée
d'étendre notre show c'était pas si
c'est exact
nous notre la première officielle
c'était le 7 avril fois que je te dirais
que dans le dernier mois de confinement
on a annulé des jambons paniers on a
reporté le match chaud le bain c'est
tout le climax au site et ont bâti un
show pour le lancer puis après say say
on se fait des plats y avait une tournée
toute la tournée était construite autour
de naples de la première y avait tout un
espèce de tournée médiatique aussi
kinect pour parler du show qui
finalement m'est tout de suite tombé à
l'eau mais pire timing genre au moment
où est ce que comme enfin ton travail
comme ça au grand jour c'est comme boire
mais exactement exactement coach blanc
par la pandémie
mais en même temps le plus grand club au
top 14
le coc vide qui est en train de le
bloquer carrément tout le showbiz
planétaire pozzerle bractées d'un côté
jeu une fois que ça fait le deuil à un
peu plus personnelle de l'afoc mon
projet moncheaux mes enfants rapidement
je pense que j'étais capable de prendre
un step back
de me rendre compte que justement comme
on disait planète terre on est tous dans
le même bateau puis en ce moment
rapidement je me suis mis en mode
solution trouver des manières de rester
créatif de chez moi plutôt que de juste
m'apitoyer sur mon sort parce que oui ça
manque les chaumes et si on n'y peut
rien il fait très bien justement mais
justement avant de débarquer dans le vif
du sujet de ce que tu fais ce temps ci
dans le folk et dates à partir des 2 ou
cela
justement si c'est l'angoissé c'est que
c'est un certain mais le mettons de
reporter annulés jusqu'à ou pire ou est
ce que en ce moment au jour où on se
parle parce que c'est du travail de tous
les jours parce que cech - grosso modo
le présentement en écho à jean mi avril
bella officiellement mes shows fin ou
sont pas reportés parce qu'il ya peu une
indication claire du gouvernement que y
aurait pas de spectacles en salle en ou
même si un lion comme annulé les
festivals et les événements sportifs
pour jusqu'à la fin de tout mais
peut-être que le temps que vous sortiez
le parc à savoir changer je pensais que
je mets toujours d astérix parce que tu
es la situation évolue de jour en jour
sur une gestion de crise en ce moment la
priorité est plus dans les chu celle des
que dans les salles de spectacle j'en
conviens sauf que le disciple temps que
la famille va falloir qu'ils donnent des
réponses un peu plus clair parce que les
diffuseurs les salles de spectacle tout
le monde est un peu sur le qui vive à
attendre un peu des chiffres clairs
parce que la programmation vous le savez
dans le monde du spectacle ces bouquets
un an et demi d'avancé parce qu'en ce
moment c'est comme s'il faut bouger les
choses il faut les replacer mais là je
peux pour placer une infinité de choses
sur jol site annuler six mois de
spectacles commenté replace il ya des
choses qui vont sauter ça va créer
espèce de bouchons incroyable avec
laquelle vouloir recommencer le titre
mon voleur façon show en même temps dit
même plus loin si c'est la survie même
des salles qui est en péril et des
salles qui que mes exemples lion d'or
qui ont fermé ils savent aussi ouvrir sa
voiture restée fermée c'est sûr que
je lisais un article je pense que c'est
le directeur du club soda qui disait que
tu es il évalue à vivre à 30000 dollars
de frais par mois une salle fermée c'est
juste un fred j'imagine administratifs
financiers
le local payé comme des dommages et une
partie du staff
j'aime beaucoup de gens qui demande
aussi d'être remboursé les chaussons
sont reportés souvent mais il ya plein
de gens qui peuvent pas maintenant que
tu change de date
ben les gens veulent être remboursés
fait qu'il faut que la salle ressortent
de la liquidité
cette année ce titre casse tête pour
tout le monde en ce moment fait moi dans
ma situation en ce moment les spectacles
de du printemps du début de l'été sur
place et à l'automne et à l'hiver
factiva première en ce moment là on
touche du bois mais si c'est octobre au
club soda
on va annoncer les dates officielles
bientôt quand ça va être nickel mais
encore là je veux dire aux gens que ma
première et en octobre c'est pas moi qui
décide de la barre même si la situation
n'est pas réglée en octobre on va
repousser mais c'est parce qu'à man il
faut quand même fou comment être
proactif consignes aux policiers de
continuer avec exact c'est off cette
offre nous on avait un tiens on avait
planifié une sortie d'un deuxième tome
de livres les deux réussites dans le
fond et on l'avait planifié la semaine
où est-ce que les commerces sont
essentielles sont fermés on avait notre
lancement
et comme notre lancement était cette
semaine le fait qu'elle sait qu'un bon
ben ok qu'il sait qu'un qui retombe ses
tablettes c'est qu'un qu'on mettra en
branle c'est quand que fait non
effectivement je comprends un peu le
sait je pense que je pense que tu l'a
bien dit avec l'incertitude créer un
petit peu la langue ouais mais c'est
vrai c'est vraiment ce qui s'est
vraiment de n'avoir aucune idée le sait
si ça pourrait être dans deux semaines
qui on recommence les activités
tranquillement comme ça pour être dans
six mois est littéralement il ya une ou
des vrais présentement c'est comme s'ils
qui nous on sait pas tout dans le sens
que le c3 mais c'est ça la face et
surtout sur les experts partagent
certains scénarios puis j'apprécie quand
même la transe
france 2 du gouvernement sur plaine
dossier en ce moment mais c'est sûr
qu'on n'a pas les infos exact que que
les scientifiques que les labos que le
gouvernement aux puits il ya plein de
scénarios c'est parce que les gens
s'entendent pop et en ce moment c'est
vraiment de la gestion de crise si j'ai
l'impression qu'ils quittent deal
l'école et plus urgents qui sont les
vies humaines puis ce seront je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord là dessus que
comme en ce moment faut gérer la crise
dans les centres les résidences le ch et
celle des puits en ce moment c'est moi
j'ai des amis de la famille qui
travaille en santé c'est mon beau frère
lui a été réaffecté dans un autre place
le staff en santé sont des [ __ ] de
héros en ce moment là paris seront
envoyés aux champs de bataille pis il ya
des places qui sont bien gérées mais je
pense que des places que c'est vraiment
littéralement le la gare hier le titre
sur un essai de socri du monde c'est
vraiment élevé pas que ce faut
relativiser le menu comment je me
considère privilégié puis quand même
chanceux de continuer à faire mes trucs
de chez nous en compromettant pas ma
santé parce que la chose la plus
importante c'est moi même ma chair et en
os talmud fait que rien à voir avec la
gestion du coc vide ces sources qui a
été réaffecté aux halles étage que 10
mai s'ils s'exposent pour triangle
orange en dec puis tout le monde aide la
cause même si c'est loin mais tu sais
pourquoi tu es rentré en médecine et
sciences non complètement 6 mai par
rapport à ton livre de recettes jeu le
savoir me semble que c'est comme
ironiquement impulser le meilleur moment
pour sortir un livre de recettes parce
que tu tout le monde cuisine
avez vous trouvé une manière de le
sortir comme de livrer ou de le sortir
en numérique plus juste c'est peu ben là
en fait le gros problème c'est que
c'était tellement proches de la date de
sortie qui était déjà livré que nos
têtes dans les librairies fait qu'en ce
moment et dans les entrepôts
d'archambault et d'entendre les
entrepôts de renaud bray dans les
entrepôts de kochko payer plus d'un dans
les entrepôts de notre éditeur fécond
même si on se disait on veut on veut
lancer l'eau là dessus par un genre de
lancement à lille on n'a pas les yeux
est parti on peut pas les rapatrie c'est
vraiment juste le mauvais temps alors je
te dis même si c'est arrivé la semaine
près genre deux jours plus tard marc
levy sortez-les c'est drôlement
m'asseoir et journalisme à leers une
copie du livre à péage
oui on avait envie mais bon on fait on
fait ce qu'on peut avec ce puits parle
en fait ce qu'on peut avec sur toi tu
fait de tes conneries l'internet dans
l'est dans les dernières semaines dans
le dernier mois en fait le jeu j'ai vu
cette publication c'est combien de 21
élèves dans le dernier mois que j'ai
fait un petit calendrier c'est quoi
exactement 21 live en un mot c'est
débile cela quelques minces que au début
au début comment ça c'est comment ça
s'est matérialisé parce que les premiers
live c'est l espèce de préposés aux
bénéficiaires lucky edel qui revenait à
son travail en somme on premier premier
live c'est en fait et je vais
t'expliquer l'agenaise jeter chez nous
quand je regarde mon calendrier si je
les vendeurs mais ça doit être au top on
est prêt si le csa non mettre cet
encadré 14 15 mars
madoff qui a fait un fait un live random
genre de sa salle de bain pour célébrer
son nombre d'abonnés sais pas quoi puis
ils m'ont invité dans son live il ya vu
que je l ai envoyé une invitation pour
être franc je pense qu'ils savaient même
pas que tu pouvais inviter du monde dans
live instagram
j'ai juste comme j'ai juste flash et
karaoké senes belle fonctionnalités le
jeu vu madoff le lendemain bonne
application
non mais ça crie ça qui est sa
spécialité le lendemain matière fin la
veille à comme glisser des vidéos dans
son live c'est je pense le début du
championnat il dit c'est des poteaux des
vidéos qui commentait face à dans un
live c'était juste comme
je voyais un peu les possibilités le
lendemain j'ai calé que le soir-même
j'allais faire un doublage d'un épisode
de ramdam en intégralité je me sois
faire des doublages sur internet mais je
trouvais que le faire en live ça amenait
comme un côté performance à la pâte en a
huit avis écrits sont toujours 2000 a
checké se savent vraiment pas ni
malheureusement je n'ai pas réussi à
l'enregistrer je savais pas que ça se
faisait encore j'étais un newbie il ya
un mois mais le live je trouvais ça trop
et le doublage trouvais ça trop
essoufflant factice je continue à penser
que j'ai eu le flash de faire comme des
lignes ouvertes s'est vu que tu peux
recevoir du monde donc on line de
trouver une manière de transposer la
fameuse lignes ouvertes à la radio que
je trouve dont 2 volts mais de le
transformer en personnage d'un prophète
brian mungo d'info santé et tombe était
pauvre et j'ai fumé 1 bat choisir la
vaisselle puis j'ai juste eu ce flash
mob je suis descendu dans mon os quelque
chose comment j'ai mis un bandage une
perruque jéhovah le live et sa partie
même les gens qui aient pu te crois
qu'il ya quelque chose en fax avec le
lendemain par des personnages chantent
également un buzz que j'ai commencé à
mettre les les live en ligne parce que
les gens aient de bonnes me demander
pour les revoir
puis j'ai fait aux personnages
21 c'est quoi les grilles des thés
évidemment le 6 et de l'impôt mais c'est
quoi le degré de préparation est ce que
tu mets ton le titre le suspense d'avoir
ton personnage ça va être quoi
évidemment mais après c'est ce que tu
sais qui tu vas y vite et ce soir
lorsque tu sais tout ceci à un gentil
gars qui est là qui est une télé le
gaucher dit
déjà au début comme après une semaine ou
deux j'ai commencé à écrire à mes amis
humoristes pour leur art by the witch et
en live du lundi au jeudi 22 heures
embarquez quand vous voulez d'expérience
généralement plus drôle quand un ami
humoriste comédien rencontre que comme
quelqu'un de random j'aime qui est un
mélange des deux mais dépendamment des
concepts aussi même juste commencer à
zéro à 1000 jeunes oreilles
venez comme collaborer ça bien comme un
sketch show improvisé
enfin que j'ai juste passé le monde mais
jamais c'était genre toi tu vas être le
tout petit j'ai jamais fait de pc c'est
vraiment je vois les gens qui se
connectent puis je les prends j'ai pas
le goût me préparer non plus tous genres
se contente pas passé assez de la
journée et après le souper jeux ds avec
mon histoire devant jeffrey morin c'est
tout à fait motivé je n'écoutais des
petits boutons et j'écoutais je sais pas
si c'est le dernier mais celui avec les
vivats d'être là les patins doit être
terminé et soufflé mon gars parce qu'il
sait de la gestion de l'hôtel publiques
entraîner jamais les perdre si tout le
temps qu'on suit pas de chiffres des
jokes en même temps qu'il offre à
rentrer du monde le k2 par le momentum
changer pour un autre c'est même ton
cerveau l'oeil et à eaunes menace en
basse
en fait j'ai réalisé surtout après la
semaine passée que c'était plus sportif
que je le pensais passer sur papier jeta
si ces supports physiques comme un show
est ce que je pouvais le vraiment des
calories mais quand je tends show jetons
pilote automatique
quand je fais mon live jetons en impro
non-stop accès
je brûle beaucoup de juges comme tu dit
réfléchir puis c'est comme si j'étais
mon propre régisseur c'est moi qui
pendant que je parle faut que je pense à
mon prochain ku j'essaie de sélectionner
j'essaie de checker dans les
commentaires qui est là pour voir qui je
peux inviter après faire un lien c'est
assez intense même mot c'est le genre de
d'adrénaline que qui me rappelle
justement les spectacles rapproche le
plus de la performance parce que c'était
rien n'excuse celui là c'est une heure
il aucun temps mort le nom senstock
médecins les gens sont là aussi puis moi
je me nourris de ce qui se passe devant
moi c'est à dire que je trouve que c'est
ça qu'est le plus payant c'est vraiment
comme s'il ya du monde qui me donne du
jus bunge c'est comme donnant donnant le
tueur mais seul face à lui on à faire
cela tout dessus un personnage une
soirée qui s'est démarqué qui y est plus
que les autres la première fois que j'ai
fait
antonio qu'ils m'ont pas
ça nage de caricaturistes vulgaire
faculté dans le fond le concept c'est
que je joue un genre de vieux france est
dégueulasse défoncé avec un jacket de
turin puis un floor jusqu'à 4-4 sur le
monde mais je les insulte en même temps
ça j'ai comme senti qu'il se passait
qualcomm je sais pas si c'est le fait
que le spo vraiment l'autre personne
parle et je crée vraiment moi-même mon
rythme j'ai sorti de l'oeuf
comment me disant moi il me semble que
c'est comme passer coati mais sinon
c'est de l'impro faille sur une heure
des fois il ya quinze minutes
extraordinaires des foyers cinq minutes
extraordinaires des fois ça l'est faut
vraiment des fois il ya juste des petits
fous rires des décrocheurs c'est faux
comme paul l'analyser comme quelque
chose de fini mais plus comme un
exercice créatif je pense
puis c'est surtout dessus toi tu viennes
l'impro l'effectif ceux ci j'imagine que
ça replonge un petit peu dans ta jeune
complètement ben ouais c'est vraiment de
l'impro peut réduire dans le sens caisse
commune mixte le site arrive devant
l'autre puis il t'amène une proposition
la différence c'est que je garde un
personnage pendant une heure mais
moustiques pour bien des gens
l'imposteur parents moi ça me nourrit ça
m'excite sam drive 6 ce côté-là de pas
savoir que ce qui s'en vient je
j'adore ça fait pas mais moi ça me
stimule et moi ça me retourne
complètement aux années au risque avant
de faire de l'humour je faisais de
l'impôt des fautes 2 3 4 semaines avec
ça me remet dans sa mère plonge dans cet
état le big time puis comment met-on
comment tu gères parce que j'étais je
n'ai pas écouté les 21 mais j'en
écoutais quand même couple puis tu
m'attends quand je faisais justement à
l'eau santé puis que c'est avec des
bottes avec justement comme tu dis des
amis humoristes qui levait qui se
maintient avec julien mettons que
pointer ou mathieu paper france qui est
arrivé qui parlait de son 1 2 si je
pense et ses boutons sur le pénis
l'algérie en crise mais mais entre ces
espèces de mama golden globes au début
tu le faisais plus une machine tu
recevais d'accepter n'importe qui
le des fois tu tombes sur un tycoon kiki
qui veut juste être vulgaire pour être
vulgaire ci est que pas vraiment rien de
com de coriandre au l'apport des mots
comme pénible aussi comment tu fais mais
ton pour essayer de garder le tempo
pendant ces moments là c'est comme un
petit prince et of petite soeur d'un
jardin d'un beat premafin king ball avec
julien pilot tu tombes sur un tycoon qui
est quand même si je fume pas vraiment
faire mais si vous passez montrer
littéralement comme un match d'impro au
cégep que des ammonites fait une super
bonne impro avec l'autre bons joueurs de
notre équipe qui est tout de suite après
tu fais une mix avec la personne qui a
par rapport à eux
la vérité c'est que j'essaie de j'essaie
de juste garder mon flow à moi puisque
c'est ça que plus le live avance puis
plus duo d'amis des gens connus puis
demande du milieu qui embarquent dans
mes lives parce que mattia un boss qui
s'est créée puis de plus en plus de gens
qui participent qui regardent enfin
qu'il ya moins de gens du public mais il
ya des concepts qui sont qui sont
offertes pour les gens du public fakih
c'est vraiment un pile ou face
la plupart des gens la plupart des gens
sont sont drôles ou ont une bonne idée
mais c'est sûr que je peux tomber sur un
lord aux outils quand j'ai fait antonio
justement caricaturiste vulgarité
j'avais annoncé le concept le sa part
même que je paye deux enfants bac à bac
6 pi ca sera pas juste d'écrire de la
maman mon but c'est que les insultes le
genre les démolit la tige peut pas
insulter une feuille de 13,1 genre tu
m'aimes quand j'ai sorti la version son
objet j'ai coupé le début même pasteur
org
j'espère que tu vas faire défoncer ta
petite gueule des merdes ce genre
d'affaires de 13,6 et ça fait partie de
ce concept conceptrice si j'avais un ou
une recherché avec moi qui filtrait les
demandes qui me faisait un piercing le
chose qu'à plus tight mais d'un autre
côté c'est pour seul concept concept
c'est moi seul
pis je trouve que les imperfections les
moments plus d'armes font que les
moments up sont vraiment plus payant
encore cette fête eu tout seul type il
est justement le succès de cette future
questionner la manière dont dans le
futur on peut utiliser la technologie
pour faire ce travail
ben je me le demande a nettement ce jeu
tish comme un peu trop dedans pour avoir
du recul sur ce qui se passe mais moi
j'ai l'impression que sap que
naturellement on va garder des on va
rester marquée par cette crise le puits
naturellement j'ai le feeling que notre
rapport aux technologies c'est au
télétravail
les gens parlent de plus en plus le
petit bain des bains des meetings qui
auraient pu être des hommes de danville
impression produite et que notre 95% des
biens etc honnêtement je pense que notre
société basée sur une pression
performance immense tu peut se traduire
par des trucs vraiment naïf mais qui
peut se traduire aussi par la dépression
des bords depuis les genres le feeling
peut pas y arriver jamais qui n'ont pas
de temps qui travaillent trop que en ce
moment on est dans un autre extrême
pensent les gens sont cloîtrés avec
leurs familles c'est ce que dit hier
intense et qui doit être comme un
travailleur qu'un parent en même temps
moi je le vis avec un bébé métier c'est
pas super et fait des siestes métier moi
j'ai des amis qui ont 2 3 aux kids en
bas âge le des kits qui veulent jouer
qui veut le socialiser tu veux la
prendre qui ont toutes des besoins
différents
ça c'est fin octobre montre que notre
rapport à la technologie
j'espère qu'on va regarder du banc parce
que la technologie ça toujours du bon ou
du mauvais c'est comment on utilise je
pense qu'on peut tout tomber accro à
notre téléphone cellulaire ses poches
mais peut-être facilitée des
communications créer dé créer des
réseaux de change + plus facile puis ça
va jamais remplacer le bon vieux comme
gearing social bon vieux rassemblement
humain c'est la présence la chaleur
physique mais je pense que peut-être ça
va pouvoir simplifier des trucs là ouais
y'a tout le monde en parle où nancy at
il dit
ils étaient quelque chose qui qui qui
faisait beaucoup de sens pour moi parce
que j'avais juste jamais réfléchi il
disait je félicite vraiment tout le
monde qui prend des initiatives sur les
médias sociaux en ce moment sauf qu'il
ya mené la nuance de dire
éventuellement va falloir arrêter de
faire ce gratuitement
parce que mettons le fait que toi chaque
soir quatre soirs par semaine des offres
1h02 d'improvisation packing drôle
gratuite gratuitement à tout le monde
qui est du contenu de qualité
ça fait que m'étant quelqu'un d'autre un
autre humoriste j'essaierai de de
monétiser en ce moment son entier comme
un artiste aimerait faire ça fait que
lui dit il ya mieux comme paul a conclu
comme pippa il part comme la la la main
dans cet échange le qu'elle est quelle
est ton opinion dans cette situation la
bonne vieille discussions de comme c'est
la faute à ce portefeuille si les jambes
vendre plus d'albums c'est la fota
dicter un service qui rate hausse
c'est difficile de mais je sais pas vous
avez impétueuse vous avez vous avez les
deux hôpitaux mais nous offre gratuite
métier les podcasts ou les podcasts ce
qu'on fait et sont gratuits à parler pas
de casque ont fait abonnés jean rameau
qui thp jones était clos pour ben sucre
âgées ou des fans mais tant qu'ils
veulent qu'ils veulent plus de contenu
qui veut plus nous entendre nous les
suspects nient avoir se sait juste qu'il
est assez bas par rapport à ce qu'est
luigi s'cusez moi je peux y compris mais
j'ai le feeling que telle ou il parle
comme un producteur puis c'est correct
c'est jusqu'à moi en ce moment
j'ai quand même eu à tuer toute la
sphère financier parce que pour
l'instant je dis je le sens qu'un buzz
lancé georges fait quelque chose qui me
stimule métiers du bateau puis ça se
traduit un engagement de fans ce gel
cinq mois ça va se traduire en vente de
billets ça va éventuellement ces trois
câbles je ne sais qui en ce moment
oui c'est gratuit mais je le sens qu'il
ya un engagement avec avec une
communauté puis que ça ça va s'inscrire
dans le futur
par contre c'est sûr que s'ils me ton
dans un deux trois mois on est toujours
en confinement compte toujours trois
autres et puis je décide j'aurais
peut-être repenser ma manière de faire
la patente
c'est généralement quand tu sais même
toutes les podcasts sur tu commences
gratos permanent et si tu sais que tu es
vraiment un coq avec les gens y aurait
peut-être manière de trouver une manière
de faire de faire payer les gens métier
pour l'instant
l'argument de six mois je le mets
gratuit ça nuit aux autres oui pinon ses
mots moi je fais ce que je fais puis si
les gens sont au rendez vous les gens
sont au rendez vous parce que tu es mon
ma job comme artiste c'est pas
d'analyser tout le marché financier du
live le tout ça fait un mois qu'on est
en crise
si on n'a aucun recul sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment demandé juste en
survie bien en résolution de problèmes
de fac louis tactile pense avec un oeil
plus bessenay spill 8 je le comprends
que genre toute sa boîte chaos tout de
suite arrêter toutes ces preuves sont
arrêtées toutes ces choses sont arrêtés
lui lui ça et rentre-dedans
économiquement moi ça oui j'aime wendake
tirs entre mathieu et des sous de côté
pour l'instant je suis pas en train de
comme si on a un filet social aussi on a
des actes gouvernementale tout le monde
moi ça va j'ai plus de dépenses le titre
je rempli le frigo date c est le genre
ça me coupe focale ça me coûte muay thaï
dati est une fois qu'ils appuient gd
donc perruque qui s'en viennent quand il
ya quelqu'un qui va venir me livrer à je
ne sais pas trop moche tu as une place
qui en ce moment ça me fait plaisir de
le faire gratos puis ainsi que dans un
mois j'aurais pas partir de là même
score mais on est tellement tôt là
dedans que
je trouve ça difficile d'analyser la
partante moi mettons pour en analysant
maintenant ce que ce qui est d'ailleurs
j'ai l'impression que dans son thème qui
lui est vraiment pessimiste par rapport
aux salles de spectacle c'est par
rapport à étayer plusieurs niveaux là
deux choses qui vont être réintégrés le
lui avait l'air de penser que les salles
de spectacle c'était vraiment pas demain
la veille que ça allait recommencer
c'est évident que je les vis de moi
c'est ça c'est une des premières
affaires qui ont coupé une des rares à
faire qui vont ramener par ce qu'en dit
le point services essentiels même s'ils
ont pour moi l'art est essentielle mais
pas un service essentiel
il ya beaucoup de proximité surtout les
grosses salles tu penses à mêler albert
rousseau saint denis deux mille
personnes cordée avec on parle pas de
deux mètres de distance l'on parle de
littéralement ton code sur le coude d'un
inconnu
c'est sûr que sur badge monde qui rit
bush sur le papier c'est possiblement la
dernière affaire qui va repartir
à moins que je sais pas l'appui je dis
n'importe quoi mais qui met vraiment des
quotas de genre qui m'incite à l'été
lajoux s'est éventuellement il parle
d'une certaine immunité collective va
peut-être que quand on va se rendre
compte qu'une partie de la population
qui le huent même que et et
asymptomatiques dans quelques mois les
banques commençaient à genre faire faire
des tests aux gens qui disent ah bon
mais toi si tu le fais tu pour sortir là
on va voir des shows devant des gens qui
ont déjà le cas vite je sais pas si ce
n'est pas ta coll il ya trop de
scénarios en ce moment mais non mais je
suis d'accord que les salles de chaud
on sait pas tout de suite laisse pas
demain la veille qu'on va vivre des gros
événements comme sa salle pour venir
justement où le financier économique de
tulle l'impression que justement le
modèle surtout sur le web change petit
tu mets ton contenue derrière un miroir
nautique foutu paix pour accéder pouvoir
voir le truc c'est quasiment impossible
d'avoir une communauté assez grande qui
déconstruit tels qu'inpex noté t on le
fait que notre petit 14 ton truc
gratuitement l'eau les gens sont
intéressés
quand les gens sont vraiment oct c'est
mettons instagram je pense que ça peut
faire ce métier mettons des plateformes
comme on commence à peine à prendre deux
gaming le top twenty two est le titre
peut faire des dons je pense le titre
uts et acquis jean bouhey s'engagerait
du pian s'attaque à moi c'est la
meilleure façon parce que justement
celui qui adore vraiment ont contenu qui
est qui qui est fan du style faire
plaisir et encourage et envoyer une
coupe des coupes de pièces uniques en a
besoin c'est facebook le fait depuis pas
longtemps que j'ai vu une alerte sur les
live facebook com est un peu comme sur
techtoc temps voit pas de l'argent
directeur aujourd'hui comme sur tout et
je pense le tout et achète une forme de
monnaie facebook
si tu achète des quads sur ton facebook
qui peut redonner ses causes le à des
artistes qui font des live
j'imagine que facebook qui se prennent
clôture ce sens que bonnes questions
j'ai même pas du tout mais sûrement
probabilité surprise mais sûrement que
oui moi je donnerai mon acompte je
donnerai mon compte de banque
enfin un live de de musique puis avec
comme un énième je passe mon temps avec
n'est pas juste comme donner de l'argent
il y avait comme un lien talent est là
dessus petit des parrains dont 10 quand
même on ne peut pas se prendre un pour
cent ne s'est pas mal de mieux prévoir
les pitchouns schiste prend t-il il
présente des pourcentages plate forme la
matière et y mettons pétulance et 20%
ainsi pris palce et 1% pour la
transaction sont encore là dessus c'est
être des affaires que j'obtiens évalué
éventuellement s'est pour l'instant
match comme j'ai jamais été très très
business entre guillemets dans le sens
où je sais pas ce qui m'intéresse moi
prime pour l'instant je considère que ce
que je fais c'est nice puis j'aime la
réponse des gens j'aime la réponse
humaine d'arras
si ammann et georges f1 team j'ai besoin
de faire du fric mais je suis pas en
train de penser tu es en ce moment genre
de demander aux artistes d'être en plus
des entrepreneurs de l'an plus réfléchir
tout les marchés économiques du live de
gimme a break le genre on est en crise
tout le monde non tout le monde essaie
juste de de faire ce qu'ils peuvent pour
comme survie continue à créer moi c'est
surtout genre créativement que je veux
rester stimuli puisque j'arrive à farouk
est non seulement de l'élève mais il ya
aussi des petites capsules vidéo deux
minutes sur facebook
chez les vidéos de conspirationnistes le
rapport rapport même si je pense que tu
étais rendu via tchéquie 11.2 millions
devious 23000 partage ça le hockey des
gens qui n'ont pas compris le niveau
malheureusement 626 et les médias
sociaux mais je m'engueule stick ça me
fatigue parce que je reçois déjà merci
autant de messages de heinze banni du
monde mon gars l'appel telle allégeant
saisissent pop tous ceux qui n'ont pas
vu leur grosse faim un faux faux vidéo
conspirationnistes mais ce quand même
pas mal clair le cul c'est une joke lé
temps beurre épais jambes et je vois
vraiment loin dans le procédé de faire
comme déformer les faits faire dire des
choses à des chiffres pitié dans la
vidéo c'est marqué que je dénonce les
familles aussi la désinformation sur ma
page ces banques là que goethe animaux
rester jose heures ça prend pas loin
gare des taxis bleus pour 4 chez que
c'est un gag
et pourtant même les jeunes mais encore
la suite une minorité de gens qui sont
comme tu dis sur 25000 partage il ya
beaucoup de gens aussi qui l'on trouvait
bonne puis je reçois des bons mots mais
à ce que j'ai comme voulu critiquer les
feuilles tenait au spi les gens me
reprocher d'en faire mais c'est la
minorité bruyante ces réseaux sociaux
c'est vraiment seul
mais le fléau est comme humainement on
est aussi conditionnée à juste retenir
le négatif là dessus si tu es mon
commentaire pour un commentaire négatif
ton cerveau focus le négatif
pourquoi mais on est fait comme ça aussi
fuck fuck sa mort c'est ça ma rentrée
dedans un peu hier j'ai commencé à lire
les commentaires et a comme juste
parce qu'elle ait jamais envoyé chier
aussi amplement message privé à manille
trouve ça drôle mais les 1 2 3 de ses
tubes bloc le monde le sait genre écrit
je fais pas ça pour ça me faire insulter
quand les frais du maule
mais c'est parce que ça vient toucher
déconne un peu sensible au site ses
légions par les gens sont anxieux
j'essaie de toujours relativiser puis
juste me dire que c'est de l'ignorance
et de la colère de la fatigue puis que
les gens veulent pas nécessairement mal
franck mais ça se traduit quand même en
imbécile it et le genre t'as pas à
menacer un humoriste a fait un job
ces personnes devraient se rendre
coupable ah ouais mais fait que les non
seulement tu avais du monde qui pensait
que c'était vraiment heureux du monde tu
avais les deux chèques tout le monde mon
analyse tollé les vrais
conspirationnistes pur et dur qui se
sentent attaqués par ma vidéo qui semble
que je ris un petit peu de
l'environnement complotistes assez peu
de gens mais y en a deux
la plupart des gens qui comprennent le
niveau qu'ils trouvent ça drôle ou non
mais qui comprennent que c'est une joke
et à l'autre côté du spectre les gens
qui pensent que moi je tends
conspirationnistes fixons comme tu dis
n'importe quoi c'est faux cheveux mais
oui c'est cela djaout madame ou monsieur
acte est un peu tout le monde quand le
mans dénué d'humour brillamment pi2
d'esprit et de discernement des
politiques de contextualisations parce
que comme il ya beaucoup d'indicés et
dans la vidéo est dans la description et
d'antichute jeu
si comme tu es moindrement curieux
hilton doute pour aix raison je
comprends pas comment tu peux avoir un
doute parce la vidéo est complètement
ridicule
mais sitôt moindrement un doute qui tu
fais aujourd'hui suite à part nos
solides en gogo ou que tu regardes sur
ma page ou utilisent des scripts la
vidéo que tu lis des commentaires en
dessous se situe le contextualise je
comprends que ce pauvre et puis ça ça me
fait pas parce que ces mêmes gens là
vont partager sûrement n'importe quoi
sur l'armée est passée bien trop
d'efforts de toutes les étapes que tu
wenders est bien trop d'effort lire deux
commentaire avant d'avoir une opinion
c'est pas 2020 et dramatique on vend ce
n'est pas bon mais sinon même ce que ça
nous dit bien on le savait parce que
c'est un peu ce que je dénonce
mais c est comme si la vidéo que je
faisais pour dénoncer ça m'avait prouver
encore plus mon point
au début j'étais juste content parce que
c'est sur c'est le fun c'est ainsi une
vidéo que bien circulé puis comme tu dis
s'est rendu à 1.3 million de vues je
pense jeu sur facebook mais souvent
souvent puisqu'il madame je vais pas
souvent ce qu'il est vraiment sur
facebook c'est quand ça fait précisément
ce que tu manges conscience à rechercher
quand ça va chercher une polarisation
puis que les gens qui s'y opposent sont
vraiment plus vocal que les gens qui
sont d'accord puisque facebook qui
capotent la tuilerie dernièrement on a
fait une publication sur un groupe
j'achète québécois j'achète locales pour
parler de nos produits vegans puis un
gars qui se posait au fait que nos
produits et époque bio mais le gaia
passé il ya du lieu du passé 24 heures
sans arrêt à répondre à tous les
commentaires mais c'est il a fait le
travail que moi j'aurais été supposé
fort ailleurs si j'aurais répondu je
remercie beaucoup mais lui répondait
tout le temps par delà un ca fait que
notre publication à le circuler à l'été
viral sur ce groupe lopy juste à cause
de ce google facebook pour tenir réseaux
sociaux comme un algorithme fonctionne
il mesure paul
mais ils mesurent pas le comment je te
dirais la qualité des commentaires une
mesure juste comme l'engagement puis le
niveau 2 le niveau d'engagement qu'une
publication va créer puis c'est sûr que
si tu as des gens qui se chicanent
forcément ça crée plus de commentaires
donc là comme la publication à être plus
viral de manière organique que si tout
le monde est d'accord avec quelque chose
change is like et le fait que les gens
commandent ce texte sont pas d'accord se
chicane et moi le sais j'ai répondu à
personne sous la vidéo passe aujourd'hui
mais le commentaire mais juste à les
voires les gens s'occupent de france que
moi je devrais faire comme tu disais si
c'est à dire que quelqu'un dise ah oui
c'est pas vrai le l'autre personnes
faustin domkeu stuc av ait pas cave le
partage de ce parti le ca fort des
lectures job comme moi je suis juste les
gens qui m'insultent en privé il est et
je réponds où je mangeais bloc en fait
toujours est il que oui en effet c'est
la haine et plus viral que d'autres
choses c'est un peu triste
il faudrait trouver une solution je
pouvais de la vidéo en penser à ça non
plus mais c'est sûr que ce qui polarise
la société naturellement va créer plus
d'engagement absolument pour 6 4 quand
tu t'attendais tu à vis des os et s'est
rendu à des endroits plus loin que qui
prend la mort aucun pays au monde où il
ya des personnes qui ont vu ta face pour
la première fois dans la revue nature
mais oui ces vidéos les plaines france
est je regarde un petit peu dans les
commentaires c'est comme généralement la
première batch de la xe et les gens
qu'il ait tapage après ça c'est les amis
des gens qu'il ait tapage j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'a pas nié le 3ème
et 4ème cercle c'est de diffusion de la
vidéo parce que c'est moche et
maintenant je regarde à matin c'était 2
millions de comptes atteint le million
de comptes atteint c'est pas juste au
québec
non c'est sûr que non c'est parce que
quand
exact commentaires sont juste positif
c'est le fun mais c'est aussi signe que
tu prêches ou aux convertis puis aux
gens qui sont qui connaissent des jeux
qui sont des jetons publique pki thème
de je te vois pas qui mais moi j'ai
toujours aimé dans ma pratique internet
mais je fais plus attention mais j'ai
toujours aimé jouer avec le vrai puis le
foot ça c'est quelque chose que je
trouve intéressant dans ma pratique de
jouer avec les codes de tir car quand je
mets ma parodie de forger dans mon char
quand je fais ma parodie de vidéos
conspirationnistes je me suis comme
utiliser un peu les codes de certains
sous genre internet pour essayer de
faire comme de la satire est repoussé au
début de ma carrière je faisais juste
des stones comme ça je faisais des faux
groupes de musique des fosses des
foreurs puis j'aime que les gens sachent
pas si c'est vrai parce que je n'ai pas
connu tout c'était difficile a approuvé
un puits mais aujourd'hui je réalise que
c'est dangereux ça parce que les gens
saisissent pas le niveau
les gens n'ont pas toujours l'esprit
critique pour démêler le vrai du faux
fois que j'essaye de maintenant donner
le plus d'indicés possibles pour que les
gens cachent le propos même malgré ce le
message passe pas toujours fraîche comme
mamani tu peux pas non plus ça y est
joseph ya comme un combat que je peux
pas non plus mener jusqu'au bout le
témoin je fais mon bout de chemin là
dedans mais je peux pas répondre à tout
le monde je peux pas non plus éduqués
comme l'esprit critique des systèmes
travail qui va se faire sur le long
terme et il faut en parler de toi il ya
tellement de fake news lotus est
vraiment dangereux beaucoup de fautes
néo soul world lycée et xsara puis
justement surtout en ce moment en
supplie justement ces temps la semaine
passée il y avait les deux journalistes
à radio canada qui ont les missions
civiles ce qui expliquait justement le
phénomène qui est en ce moment
tout le monde est sur internet comme on
est anxieux qui justement dans une crise
comme ceux le situent tous les éléments
sont réunis pour que qui faisant il est
fait que new style théories de complot
ce justement ce pour ce d'autant plus
que la vidéo tombait à point pika touche
une corde sensible
moi je les sorties en réaction un peu à
ça c'est à dire que j'ai vu une vidéo
qui m'a particulièrement déprimées de
conspirationnistes l'a jeté comme ça
s'peut pas piste et c'est dans l'air du
temps il ya des vedettes québécoises
commence à partager du stock
puis j'ai vu l'autre vise justement à
tout le monde en parle
puis jetée comme mon premier réflexe est
que ça me déprime type ça me fâche
parce que ça montre une partie de
l'humanité que je trouve triste le site
adil l'ignorance la désinformation et
c'est normal d'être fâché c'est normal
d'avoir perpétué en ce moment il ya un
sentiment d'impuissance immense par
rapport à cette crise l'autre puis ça
c'est peut-être des sentiments super
légitime et c'est tout là toute
l'ignorance il le fait que tu me ton les
gens deviennent raciste envers les
communautés chinoises c'est que comment
est ce que cette misère là va se
transformer en animal placé sa main
vraiment ça m'affecte factice mon
premier réflexe en général quand j'ai
quand je vis à vis de l'intérioriser
bien précieux j'essaie de trouver une
manière comme créative de le sortir
c'est souvent ça passe par les mots mais
dans mon cas ça a été rappelé aux tic de
le faire c'est j'écoute
j'ai passé une journée coûte des vidéos
de conjoints de théories du complot
j'étais genre je t'ai pas bien cette
journée l'a jeté comme pourquoi je me
fais ce style il ya plein de jeux pour
toutes les mettre dans le même panier
lotis je suis moi-même un sceptique sur
plein de choses je pense qu'en effet ce
qu'avec de ce questionnaire ne pas
prendre tout pour du cash mais quand ça
s'en va à l'encontre de ce que la
communauté scientifique que la
communauté médicale
jose ramon est fausse faut arrêter notre
confiance à certaines choses à un
certain savoir empirique et puis je
trouve que quand tu remettre tout en
question ça mène à rien parce que on
pourra jamais tout prouver nous mêmes
c'est faut amener asseoir notre
confiance puis de tout remettre en
question mais de commencer a cité comme
source un esti d'owendo en france ou un
artisan youtube si c'est comme la
ressource a pas de bon sens le souvent
conspirationnisme c'est comme sa source
est un vieux youtube par claire c'est
comme tu peux pas non plus tu peux pas
utiliser les mêmes méthodes malhonnêtes
que tu critiques aux médias de masse
pour passer finalement ton pointe
je trouve que ceux ci c'est malhonnête
et puis quand tu quand tu t'arrêtes à
écouter puis à réellement prendre le
temps de consommer c'est ce genre de
théorie lol tu réalises à quel point la
pensée commune à quel point en fait on a
une chambre d'écho est-ce que ça c'est
pas c'est pas envisageable ni du whisky
comme des faux j'ai des fois que
j'écoute ou je vois passer un article
mais dont le mot g/j un gars dans mon
facebook que je sais même pas pourquoi
il est dans mon facebook évidemment je
ne nommerai pas là mais je sais même pas
pourquoi ils m'ont fait votre justice et
qui met il pas mon ami pas qui lui
systématiquement il va prendre
il va il vas y vas chalet sur les
mesures gouvernementales mais
systématiquement puis il va toujours
trouver un article pour appuyer appuyer
la raison pourquoi chelsea parce que ça
existe le team est temps que tu veux
écrire mais admettons que tu écris sur
google n'importe quoi tu retrouvé un
article qui prouvera que de 2004 qui dit
que l'on teste un vaccin en afrique
contexte supports différents
en utilisant juste l'aide line ou
carrément juste un article de blog d'un
institut r parce que c'est sale affaire
aussi c'est comme c'est pas vrai que
tous les médias et toutes les sources
sont équivalentes
ah oui c'est certain que vu que c'est un
lien http ça une crédibilité ça une
valeur et crise non mais moi je peux me
faire un lien web qui dit les nuages
sont des chemtrails pu mettre ça en
ligne n'importe qui va pouvoir le
partager avec un vrai de la nuit mon
site s'appelle peut-être le monde.fr
figaro oui c'est de la stib d'amples
tops met ça donne un faux sentiment de
légitimité tunisie dit justement des
choses comme ça parce que le parcours tu
réfléchis que tu pense que c est
peut-être que ça c'est ce style mais
dans google vous trouvez quelqu'un qui a
dit que c'était ce 4ème année
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut arrêter de
réfléchir c'est vrai qu'il ya des
affaires chez helline dati comme ça en
train de sortir que justement la chine
et ont trafiqué nombre de copies de mort
wade il faut rester au fait si
l'information le possesseur que tu as
des régimes politiques vraiment chéri
comme la chine qui bon la russie qui
vont pas traiter la ford la même manière
utile de la corruption
il y en a partout il y en a il y en a eu
au québec il y en a encore au québec des
jeux de pouvoir ça ça existe puisque
important de rester critique c'est juste
qu'en ce moment tout le monde
s'improvise journalistes ou enquêteurs
et n'importe qui qui veut conforter son
sentiment qu'on nous cache quelque chose
parce que c'est un sentiment que les
gens vivent en ce moment d'impuissance
de colère de puits d'impuissance mais
c'est juste qu'elle fut scellée manière
dont ce sentiment le poste radio je
trouve qu'ils sont super inquiétante eu
malentendu
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas se
questionner ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pop genre continuent à une journée tout
à la recherche de notre vérité en
quelque part mais le le ça prend des 900
prend des proportions complètement
ridicule en ce moment puis il ya plein
d'affaires qui sont faciles à démanteler
team dont tout le monde parle de bill
gates à ce moment comme étant genre le
gars qui veut vacciner pour éliminer en
particules à l'humanité comme je
comprends même pas à quoi ça pourrait
tenir la route métier
les gens disent qu'il y aurait dit dans
une conférence qui voulait qu'ils
voulaient comme tout une partie la
population métier j'ai lu un article là
dessus puisqu'il ya dix c'est juste que
idéalement pour que la terre puisse sûr
il faudrait trouver faudrait penser à
décroître la croissance de l'humanité de
temps pour s'en sort tant d'années ça
veut pas dire de tuer personne parce que
c'est juste de manipuler certains
d'idées certains mots pour faire passer
un nouveau message s'estompe lance-t-on
plan c'est de tuer une partie de
l'humanité est ce que tu vas les
dirigeants une conférence
mettons que tombe la rimac temps plein
deux docteurs terreur le sida c'est
comme d'anéantir jean petites voitures
sur les coques pour en parler
un tube ce nom mais christ un bon point
[ __ ] c'est ça comme tu veux une rançon de
plusieurs milliards de dollars
le sauveur série culte je vais enfin
bits sur le les gens qui pensent
l'attend les plates dit ok maintenant
que la terre est plate
je veux bien mais pense à tous les gens
que ça impliquerait comme qu'il faudrait
mettre dans le coup ces gens pensent
qu'on n'est même pas de s'organiser
genre en micro passe à l'échelle
immunitaire comment faudrait il assez
génial sable et de l'eau mais déjà tout
les gens qui ont des bateaux
il faudrait que tous les propriétaires
de bateaux sache qui a ramené obs
la terre a drop de même pense à tous les
gens que ça implique un complot comme ça
c'est impossible l'humain est trop
désorganisée c'est comme on n'hésite
plus à contrôler ses on aime l'idée de
comme une espèce de groupe qui achètent
c'est que même toi tu viens la vie
politique américaine sont même pas grave
de gérer une fois qu'ils comptent tous
éteints puis il rend complot planétaire
sur un vaccin pour faire un ménage
l'humanité puis à quel prix aussi c'est
comme moi je sais quand je pense qu'on
plonge de penser qu est ce que ça
rapporterait aux gens qu'ils font sur
mathias moment dessus ferme toutes les
économies
en train de ralentir l'économie mondiale
tu plonges compris dans une réalisation
ya peu de gens qui gagnent en ce moment
quoi que ce soit de cette crise la fac
puis de ces mêmes même l'argument de
ceux qui gagnent quelque chose c'est
même l'argument mettons des compagnies
pharmaceutiques loi émeutes ont ce
qu'ils font le vague en ce moment en ce
moment mettons les les scientifiques qui
travaillent sur un vaccin j'écoutais mon
entrevue sur deux des lidd et le podcast
du new york times ou est-ce qu'il
parlait à la chef de l'équipe c'est une
équipe en allemagne qui travaillent sur
le vaccin ils sont comme dans le top 3
des fronts froids norbourg qui va
trouver le vaccin
elle c'est la semittel en termes de
recherche pour ce vaccin là précisément
qui est la 18e même l ate octobre peuple
à dion on sait même pas qui va avoir le
vaccin
j'en sais même pas quelle compagnie
veulent trouver parce qu'en ce moment
c'est comme tout le monde se partage les
informations
tout le monde travaille pour pousser
égal parce que vlof pa kings 3 mois on
n'avait aucune idée que c'était la
créative fait quand même les compagnies
pharmaceutiques qui aurait pas pu
planifier ce type aurait pas planifié
seraient en somalie youpi aux personnes
qui auraient pu avoir ce vaccin est là
avant que la crise commence t parce que
les scientifiques les plus à la fine
pointe sont mais ils l'ont même sac mais
je pense que l'idée du complot est quand
même le fun puis moi quand j'étais ado
j'en écoutais chier des vidéos de
conspiration que j'ai toujours aimé
cette idée là qu'on nous cache quelque
chose que on fire beger bigger picture
tea mais après ça le problème je trouve
précisément dans ce moment si c'est que
les gens qui diminue le l'importance du
virus qui disent aux gens mais ils nous
mentent le confinement ça sert à rien
mais il met à risque la santé publique
c'est ce que je trouve que saab est
encore plus dangereux c'est quand
l'ignorance crasse traduire par un
danger sur les vies humaines mais j'ai
le feeling c'est ce qui va arriver si on
prend pas si on prend pas la chose au
sérieux c'est sûr je pense qui
m'inquiète dans ce contexte
parce que tu es borrat mme line chez moi
dans la vie de tous les jours si tu
pense qu'on n'a pas marché sur la lune
comme fine on va en parler mais ça
change rien genre comme si dans le passé
c'est le fun qui on peut en parler puis
tuer mais je pense pas que ça vraiment
d'impact journaux vite
non seulement ces sorties c'est
dangereux pour les autres dangereux pour
eux-mêmes le tri il ya des gars qui sait
s'automédicamenter en buvant son
nettoyeur à wahaha coirier yéti dans le
fond y avait épuisé j'ai pu me une coupe
de cheveux de médicaments qui pense que
peut-être pour être un remède mais c'est
pour la queen b il ya celui là mais elle
a trois quatre autres je sais pas si
lequel parce qu'il y en a eu que but
comme il ya vu ce qu'ils avaient sedan
1,6 à faire dans une maison c'est pour
nettoyer son aquarium n'a pas comme ceux
qui aiment les bouteilles au complet
mais tu vois qu'ils épient non seulement
pis mais même les flatteurs s'il ya un
doute s'est construit une fusée ya dix
mois je veux aller je monte toujours
trouvé que ce qui est plate
ces envoyés dans l'air mais depuis je
veux pas faire des jobs sur les gens qui
se tuent parce que ça reste un drame
mais c'est tout ce qui est l'idée n'est
pas dangereux
l'idée du darwinisme un peu la sélection
naturelle voilà c'est bien je trouve
qu'il ya encore comédie la nuit mort
c'est comme lire ni même de seul c'est
de vouloir prouver quelque chose au
point de se situer
c'est comme ça s'invente police comme le
quart mode un peu mais ça reste un drame
le chaque personne qui tue c'est pas
drôle mais aussi comme geissmann genre
j'ai pas le choix c'était combat c'est
comme il ya des gens formés en sciences
com et ses potes ça me fait rire cette
idée l'aide de faire de la science toi
même pourquoi est ce que toute la
communauté scientifique planétaire
voudrait nous cacher quelque chose comme
à quoi ça rime gens je comprends pas que
c'est ça ton
ton moteur dans la vie genre ce que je
comprends par contre c'est le
documentaire sur les flatteries toys pas
bon sur netflix parce que tu comprend en
fait l'idée de communauté dans les erp
sap puis je pense que c'est ça qui drive
n'importe quel groupe que ce soit des
groupes d'extrême droite fasciste que ça
soit des groupes et des sectes y pid que
ça soit des idéaux de gauche de droite
peu importe l'idée de communauté super
important pour l'être humain a besoin de
se rassembler en tribu puis le sentiment
de tout les complotistes en ce moment
ils sentent qu'ils appartiennent à une
même famille ceux qui sont à la
recherche de la vérité ils se partagent
des informations puis je suis convaincu
qu'en ces moments d'isolement
ces gens là se sentent se sentent
rassurés de de faire partie d'une
communauté la communauté en soi est très
douteuse mais je peux pas leur enlever
le on peut leur enlever ce réconfort de
sentir qu'ils appartiennent à une
famille parce qu'on a tous besoin de
tout
c'est un bon point et puis ça jamais été
aussi facile de se sentir appartenir à
un groupe toujours avec internet on va
essayer littéralement des groupes d'amis
sur facebook téléchargement un groupe ça
tu peux joindre un groupe s'est fixé
c'est même pas le nom et le badge quand
tu es fan de coloriage jedessine te
donne l'adresse d'une page de maresches
comme sly 4 6 tati c'est madonna bad tu
commentes courage sans doute je voulais
qu'on parle un peu pour revenir un petit
peu at et live que tu fais ça donne ça
donne lieu à des moments qui sont sur
réel puis moi j'ai c'est sûr que je
pense tout de suite on a parlé de
l'homme avant qu avant qui est joint à
nous je pense que tu as à l'épisode avec
10 codes de haut des grues de données en
un moment complètement surréel pis il ya
plusieurs couches à ce que s'est passé
pour ceux qui qui qui savent pas qu'on
parle peut aller voir sur youtube
je vous laisser le plaisir d'observer le
mr match mais il ya plusieurs affaires
qui se passe là dedans parce que moi je
t'ai l'appareil mais je regardais de
seppi s'est il ya vraiment un espèce de
moment où est ce que tout le monde était
là mais tout le monde était le tout
toutes les personnalités publiques qui
sont durs le moindrement actif durant la
pandémie tout le monde était le tout le
monde commentait dans le chao pilat est
arrivé le moment avec jessica qui on
dirait que on dirait que tout le monde a
été a été jeté par terre dans cette
situation là était la vérité le picom je
veux pas spoiler même temps ce qui s'est
passé c'est que c'était quand même
clermont ultime au personnage tant ceux
qui l'ont pas vu c'est un genre de
chroniqueurs du chroniqueur patins genre
journaliste showbiz fait que mon
personnage très très à la recherche de
paternité
ce qui est cool le stub live la ses clés
comme tu dis les vedettes sont au
rendez-vous à steve passe de gouverner
cloutier à 80 ans marianne mazza après
ça on s'en va au panier asti anik jean
s'étouffer lavoine imité après ça on
rentre justement dans une bâche plus
champagne la campagne est venu façon
perso si l'on rentre plus dans une
gangue justement d'autres
est ce que tu es fou c'est que les gens
parlaient de quelqu'un d'autre mais la
personne tels la faculté j'allais
chercher la perse l'autre vedette les
gens se répondaient fait qu'il y avait
une espèce de bild à magic que je
n'aurais pas pu écrire que c'était
vraiment genre salve ça se passait là
justement le gag c'est que les gens
inventent et des faux scoop tout le
temps puis moi j'allais comme des ratés
ce jeu-là savoir sur la vie sexuelle des
gens plus âgés skate à l'ue a été une
révélation qui que ça soit vrai ou non
ses joues en torche ce ça lui appartient
puis pour vous re s est vraiment fort
sympa le point c'est juste que ça c'est
comme si elle avait amené le game à un
autre niveau parce que sa révélation
elle l'a tellement dit genre comme si
c'était vrai la charge peut pas le dire
à qui je vole 10 heures
quand on dirait que ça ajoute de l'eau
non ben oui c'était mais en fait en fait
pour pour pourrait pour corriger ce que
tu viens de dire ça l'a pas emmené le
truc à un haut niveau ça le juste eu
hélas peut-être ça juste fini genres sa
fille lui magnan voici la fonderie d'un
point de vue de timing juste pour finir
si on parlais tantôt lé momentum dans un
live c'est difficile à contrôler des
fois tombée à un moment il y arrive dans
les cinq premières minutes
là c'est comme le live il faisait
vraiment ça il jaillit
on le sentait l on le sentait tout le
monde embarque comme le rebelle de la
locomotive continue ali il restait
peut-être cinq minutes alive tient après
une heure les lames instagram est close
si moi j'avais pas le goût d'en faire
plus parce que je te brûler le jay ce
qui est arrivé avec ce thème avec ce
moment là le stage hors congés quand
même moi j'avais décroché que j'avais
fait à l'église on vient de survivre aux
petits jetons comme ok on est neuf mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe
le j'essayais de penser à d'autres
choses parce que non plus je voulais pas
tomber dans un mode où est-ce que ridel
piqué 0 puis ça jamais des zéros pointés
les foules fo le banjo si tu cherches je
retourner la voir je vais attaquer c'est
une job je les lui laisser la parole
mais la jallère pas là d'autres gens qui
étaient comme stephen jay scott c'est
tout le monde parlait l'autre coach déjà
yahoo j'ai perdu le contrô le jeu tu
allais sur champagneur pencher là dessus
mais comment s'était senti le coup le
dire qu'il est allé trop loin
le concept même de mon live c'est que vu
que sport organisé ses lives tout ça
c'est que j'ai pas contrôler sur la
moitié de ce qui se dit c'est moi je
contrôle sur moi mais après coup je me
suis dit j'ai toujours été correct avec
les gens j'ai dû forcer le jir tchèque
et l'extrait j'ai dit non je pense était
cool j'ai le le ton était clair j'écris
à jesse jane austen rowland christ sans
les accès et comment et pourquoi ce
jusqu'en fin jeudi parfaitement que bien
que ce match en jeu juste pas non plus
jamais tomber dans un mode qui
c'est juste que ça reste 5 pour tout le
monde peu chaotique que les gens catch
que moi j'instaure juste vraiment un
cadre créatif au pour m'amuser avec du
monde puisque c'est ce que je veux ce
soit très clair mais elle était super
bonne joueuse et match conscients que ça
fait beaucoup parler le tuer parce qu'il
s'est passé de quoi live je pensais
vraiment le côté life 2 you when the
city mall est jamais qu elle apprécie à
manger j'ai des bruits fait le show
est-il en freestyle avec du monde les
gens m'appelaient yorkais ce qui s'est
passé 5 mois juste la fin des jo
je pense que tout l'épisode était plutôt
complet ben ouais tout au complet qui
est inique sillonnent nos 1000 personnes
tout tu laisses tes live 24 g et laisse
sur ma page mais ça monte à cayenne
c'est ça c'est ça que j'allège allait
poser comme question si une 1000
personnes qui regardent live quand les
semences du monde qui ont directement
j'ai regardé sur youtube sur you tube
till que je n'avais pas les commentaires
du monde qui te laisse sur instagram non
c'est se battre mais mais tant que je
peux aussi être un moyen de le faire
en fait c'est bien moi je fais affaire
avec un gars qui a une version instagram
qu'il peut il peut les télécharger la
version sans commentaire que je trouve
la plupart du temps c'est plus le fun
pas de commentaire mais pour seul si je
leur fais le
ouais ça aurait pris deux kilos ouais
parce que moi donne mais ce que je veux
c'est ça c'est ça moi c est précisément
cet exemple qui m'a marqué c'est comme à
10 e jesse james après sa révélation
puis le premier la première personne qui
réagissent et véronique critique fait
comme quoi faire de niveau 6 au niveau
même michael omagad 6 et puis tout le
monde réagissait mais moi c'est vraiment
verrou qui m'a marqué parce que comme
quand j'étais petit verrou à alénya
fureur pis si vraiment c'est au magazine
sport au québec la ccam acquis non
berrou était là qu'un quintet avec deux
histoires en parallèle t'avais
l'histoire du live
est avait l'histoire des commentaires
des gens qui en parlent et puis
honnêtement si j'ai à refaire cet
épisode là je vais trouver une manière
je pense jean faure pas que justin video
capture screen du replay au complet
pendant une heure pour avoir les
commentaires parce que en effet je suis
conscient que ça ça fait partie de
l'expérience montre que james soit soit
être sérieuse ou soif outanane au score
parce que c'était trop pour moi je pense
que la fille bright parce qu'elle aussi
elle a quand même un fleurs pour pour
faire parler
seppi dans tous les cas et puis
honnêtement c'est pas un vrai scandale
quand les services s'y sont cassé sa
sexualité
ce qui était faux c'est comme s'il y
avait une rupture à ce moment là dans ce
show parce que si on s'entend que je
suis venu te parle à pierre-luc funk dub
step and cry c'est pas le cas je lai
déguisé c'était dix groupes au centre
for clean random plus on savait juste
l'art comme ça pour être vrai il s'écrit
ici tout le monde se demande déjà à
tchatcher 70 qui venait d'embarquer dans
life catch up ça qu'on veut te demander
à quelqu'un je suis le niveau elle a
tellement bien joué autre que faut il
donner il faut donner le crédit futur et
honnêtement je pense que dans tout l'est
comme agir dessus j'ai reparlé à just
kids suspect car en genre elle assume à
100 % puis c'est un bon coup dans tous
les cas parce que on en parle mais c'est
important de rappeler que je te masse
c'est parce qu'elle a dit a tant que tel
parce que je dis c'est pas grave c'est
pas sympa car pour rien
l'espèce de justement comme site il ya
une rupture il ya eu comme il y avait de
l'ironie plomb on savait plus on était
dans le réel dans l'ironie psy c'est ce
qui m'a gic puis quand j'en parlais
tantôt que j'aime jouer avec le vrai
paul fotsé j'aime mon live d'avs la
journée d'avant je faisais mon
personnage de conspirationnisme pendant
une heure
m simon olivier fecteau est arrivé il ya
foule sérieux puis joël sceptiques qui
me confronter les gens m'écrivent est
est ce que simon olivier comprend que
c'est un personnage l'acheter comme ben
oui évidemment si il me connaît il sait
que je peux conspirationnistes mais
c'était tellement rire comment il a joué
ou l'angle qui a apporté que les gens
d'al dans les commentaires du genre yo
je pense que simon y compris c'est ça
qu'on crée une confusion qui se trouve
sa source à ceyrat on navigue dans cette
zone à qui je tends personnage mais
c'est pas tout le monde qui est un
personnage
des fois je ressentais comme le gersois
alex champagne qui est un personnage
mais tout de suite après je reçois avec
jean qui est chez elle sont schmid dans
le sait comme on sait fut qu'est ce qui
est vrai qu'est-ce qui a pu voir sache
que je te parle d'un autre oeil votre
tabarnak ces crises et c'est la grosseur
de son bar tu sais comme réellement d'un
niveau d'absurdité en même temps j'ai
payé quelque chose de magique un peu la
donne
et puis j'espère avoir la chance de
revivre des moments même avec le live
parce que tu pour vous c'est tellement
jouissif comme d'arriver à des moments
où est-ce que non seulement aux vicieux
mais on le vit ensemble
je pense que côté événementiel du live
qu'il faut que ça soit un show où une
émission de télé exactement c'est ça les
change que ça creek qui centrait nourrit
justement yo yo comme pas vraiment c'est
comme nouveauté munich n'est pas
vraiment d'autres plateformes qui
auraient pu y créa d un possible même à
la télé je reste jamais jamais réussi de
toute ma vie à avoir sur le même show
kart levac marianne ahmad jaber annie
cloutier pierre luc funk louis
morissette
c'est qu'il y avait dans un show d'une
heure c'est un plus gros pressing et
n'importe quel tout le monde en parle
qui moi je vais pas nier seul mon
sous-sol gratos avec une connexion
ethernet médium 1 jeudi à 22h que c'est
si oui mais les gens sont disponibles
les gens sont connectés pis si je vous
annonce que je vois leur faim c'est un
personnage lui quand je vois leur faire
les gens vont être pris elle parce que
il ya des dossiers à régler
et puis je veux pas spoiler rien métier
- charlotte car des émeutes ont quatre
semia comme chez des flèches à charlotte
car des caps qui vole les genres les
comptes le maintien
charles kao à vol tout mais contre
attaque volent tout me guigues music as
fait charlotte est mort et écrivain
comme je veux répondre à ce genre les
gens embarquent les gens qui suivent si
je peux créer encore plus de deux
réseaux d'eau potable qui sait il y aura
peut-être d'autres moments magiques
comme peut-être que jesse ou renault
vont vouloir nous faire le point sur la
france mais je vais me forcer personne
mais la tribune elle existe dit en ce
moment je sens qu'on peut avoir ben du
fun avec ce pour un but c'est vraiment
juste avant de laisser partir le un
petit mot sur eux sur le conte l'espèce
de challenge de la ligue champagne
d'essayer de te faire décrocher le bois
c'est la fédé glas la fatigue la mode et
la fonte des glaces est probant le
moment qui me fait le plus rire de la
dernière année alex champagne avec un
condom un truc dégueulasse coups
puissants et péter neuf d'entre eux ont
changé il m'a montré le lendemain y
avait encore des marques de vieux
lubrifiants genre de yeux puis c'est
alex et puis juste pour rire d'un petit
alex moi je le connais depuis un bout
parce qu'il faisait de l'impro on avait
le même coach de l'impro quand il lui
est au cégep moi j'étais au secondaire
c'est un gars que j'ai évidemment j'ai
suivi quand il entre à l'école l'humour
il ya pas de contrôle jacques roberge si
c'est pour moi c'est culte
c'est un gars que j'ai toujours trouvé
puissant il ya plein de monde qui l'ont
découvert par la suite c'est avec trois
fois par jour ça que ça il sait comme si
le game et le projet il ya bien des gens
qui ont comme oublier qu alex yahoo ou
acquis aucune dexter d'humoristes
billets mais comme c'est comme système
exactement le genre à alexis et faune
e-mails et il fait de la photo il fait
ce projet entreprendre en haleine à ses
livres mettez moi pour moi alex a
toujours été un gars fort qui nie la
rente
puis il m'a dit que ça lui a fait du
bien c'est leur boulot parce que c'est
comme si ça lui donne le droit
pardon de se plonger dans l'humour ce
vraiment de manière décomplexée puis
spontanée ça se préparer parce que des
fois ça peut être anxiogène si tu peux
faire un retour en humour tu que tu fais
chauffer une grosse capsules à qui et
comment je fais ce que le ces genres you
il se connecte fait son gag
ça donne le goût de revenez y est
toujours vraiment en mode faut que je
fasse rire fac non c'est devenu genre
comme mon acolyte numéro un des lives
qui si c'est des moments que je n'aurais
pas pu prévoir il ya un mois que
j'allais autant rire avec alex champagne
ce qui est un gars que je connais mais
qui est pas mal plus grandes chambres
dans le milieu le du genre comme un beau
hasard puis en ce moment tant mieux si
lui s'amuse tant mieux si aussi plein de
gens qu'ils leur découvre comme le go
for king rampant c'est un des gars qui
me fait le plus rire au monde c'est avec
champagne ceci comme choucha cool de le
voir s'épanouir là dedans c'est clair
merci merci beaucoup
est ce par le fonds va cesser lundi au
jeudi 22 ans pour l'instant ça c'est pas
du cam en et comme selon les ordres de
louis morissette ça va être payant 4 les
hommes selon généralement pour l'instant
c'est ça que je calme et ici à man et je
commence à trouver ça tough jeu
je ne ferme pas l'idée d'en faire moins
ou de le penser différemment pour
l'instant lundi au jeudi 22 heures sur
mon compte instagram et jamais je n'ai
jamais en ligne sur youtube de manière
aléatoire jacomet des vieux
j'en ai pour des pâtes 5 6 mais je
continue en applaudissements youtube
puis
mccoleman merci beaucoup d'avoir choisi
la main et à sang ont surfé sur un
studio après ouais y'a aussi